Sen
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
hiç terk ettiniz mi evinizi işinizi
doğup büyüdüğü şehri çok sevdiğiniz
Hatta aşık olduğunuz gibi Ne peki ya
kendinizi terk ettiniz mi kendini terk
etmek bununla ilk kez Hoca saramago'nun
bilinmeyen Ada'nın öyküsü kitabında
tanıştım adayı görmek için adadan dışarı
çıkmak adayı terk etmek gerekir diyordu
kitapta İnsan kendi içindeyken nereden
bilebilir ki kendini Eğer kendinden
çıkamazsan eğer kendini terk etmez sen
kendini görmenin ve kim olduğunu
bilmenin mümkün olmadığını anlatıyor
kitap ve Avara Bu bir geminin bir
kıyıdan ayrılması
Bu ayrılık Nedense hep negatif geliyor
kulağımıza Gerçekten öyle mi Sezen
Aksu'nun şarkısı da söylediği gibi
o Her Ayrılık Bir Vurgun Değmeyin
yaşlarıma
Benden selam söyleyin bütün aşklarıma ve
Selda Bağcan söylüyor
Ayrılık Ayrılık Aman Ayrılık Herbir
dertten alan yaman ayrılık gerçekten Her
Ayrılık Bir Vurgun mu bu kadar Yaman mı
bu kadar olumsuz bu kadar kötü bir şey
mi ve hatta gelin bir adım daha ileri
gidelim ayrılığı mı tercih edersiniz
terk etmeyin
Sen hangisini tercih edersiniz ilk önce
aradaki farkı paylaşın
Bu ayrılıkla terketmek Eylem olarak
Aslında aynıdır ama iç anlamları
farklıdır
terketmenin içinde sevgi ve zorunluluk
da vardır bir aile düşünelim Eğer çocuk
evden çıkarsa Bu ayrılıktır ama aynı
evden ayrılan kişi anne ya da baba ise
bu Terk etmeye girer ve avarya limandan
ayrılmak ya limon da tekne Aslında
güvendedir her şey yolundadır ama uzun
süre orada kalırsa oradan ayrılmazsa bir
süre sonra o teknenin altı çürümeye
başlar şükrünü vermek için ayrılık
zorunludur O yüzden de bazen
birilerinden bazen bir şeyden Hatta
kendimizden ayrılmamız gereklidir Bugün
sizi ayrılıkla barıştıracağım Ayrılığın
güzelliklerini anlatacağım Hatta
kendimizi terketmenin büyüsünü size
keşfet bu
dünyaya gelmek başlı başına bir ayda
hikâyesidir yuva bildiğimiz annenin
karnından ayrılıkla başlar Hayat bebek
doğarak mevcut yuvasından ayrılmakta ve
yepyeni bir alana geçmektedir ilk
ayrılıkla yaşam başlar LOL bebek için
beslenme süreci geldiğinde bu süreçte
annesinin memesini Kendisinin
bilmektedir ne zaman ki anne memesini
çocuktan çektiğinde bebeğin bilinci de
ben duygusu dosyası açılır Çünkü memenin
kendisine ait olmadığını öğrenme süreci
başlamıştır
bebek ikinci ayrılığı
sahiplendiği memeden uzaklaşınca anlar
İlkin annesinin karnını kendi yuvası
bilen ardından emdiği sütü kendisine ait
zanneden bebeğin Bu ayrılıkla biraz daha
ben olma duygusu beslenir Ayrılık o
kadar da kötü değilmiş Ne dersiniz devam
edelim emeklemek ten yürümeye geçişte
böyledir bebek onlarca kez düşer fakat
Yılmaz vazgeçmez düştükçe kalkar
kalktıkça düşer en sonunda elini tutan
destek olmaya çalışan annesinden En
azından veya koltuktan ayrılır kendi
başına ilk adımı atar ve bir adımda
bütün düşüşlerini temize çeker tek bir
adımla bir halden başka bir hale geçer
fark etmeye başladınız mı aslında insan
kendine ayrılıklarla erişir
ardından okul süreci başlar mezuniyetler
ilkokul ortaokul lise üniversite çok
sevdiğimiz okulumuzdan sınıfımızdan
sınıf arkadaşlarımdan Hatta sıra
arkadaşlarımızdan ayrılırız hüzünlenir
iz mutsuz oluruz ama her terk ediş
heryeri okul bizi bir üst seviyeye taşır
ama bazen doğduğumuz büyüdüğümüz yeri
terk etmek zorunda kalırız çok zordur o
sevdiğimiz bilindik yerlerden
bilinmeyenlere gitmek evimizden sıcacık
aile yuvamızdan ayrılmak Gelin size
kendi hikayemi anlatın Ben Suyu
elektriği yolu olmayan bir köyde doğdu
büyüdü Annem ilkokul mezunu bir köy
kadın ama nice profesörlerden
öğrenmediğim Hayat derslerini annemden
oran rahmetli babam köye liselerinden
mezun olağanüstü bir ve ben onun
sayesinde Anadolu Lisesi'ni kazandı Ve
köyden sonra ilk kez şehre gittim hem de
yatılı bıdaha ufacık bu ve bilmediğin
bir şehre gitti
Evet şu fotoğrafı görüyor musunuz sağ
alt köşedeki masum köylüyü Evet çok zor
ama o bir yıllık yatılı hayat hayatı
boyunca tek başıma da kalsam her şeyi
bana başaracağını İspat eder beni bir
üst seviyeye Taşıyan harika bir terk
ediş oldu ve ilişkiler sevdiğimiz halde
aşık olduğumuz halde çok istediğimiz
halde bazen olmaz Bazen terk ederiz
bazen terk edebiliriz O an çok kötü
gelir dünya başınıza yıkılır günlerce
haftalarca
ağlarız unutamayız ama gün gelir zaman
geçer hayat bambaşka boyda taşınıra
Deniz geçmişte böyle bir ilişkim vardı
ama ondan öğrendiklerimiz de bir üst
seviyeye geçeriz ve gelelim İş hayatını
bazen işimizden ayrılırız işimizi terk
ederiz yıllarımızı verdiğimiz hayatımızı
verdiğimiz işinizden İstifa ederiz ya da
kol buluruz bakın yine size kendi Ne
anlatayım ben ilk iş hayatında Finans
Bank'ta başladım yurtdışına gönderilmek
üzere Bundan daha güzel ne olabilir ama
sevmedim Sevemedim ve ömrümü Ben böyle
geçmek istemiyorum yurtdışına
göndereceğiz Sen dediler istemedim ve
istifa ettim etrafındaki herkes Yapma
etme nasıl fırsatı tekersin dediler ama
ben mutsuzluk Ben kabuğunu kırmak
istedim gittim Askerliğimi yaptım geldim
ve sonra dış ticarete başladım ve ondan
sonra Dünya'yı Gezdi ve Bayar Bayern
gibi uluslarası kıymada ülke müdürlüğü
yaptım ve bir süre sonra baktım ki
istediğim şekilde gitmiyor yine istifa
etti etrafındaki bir çok işi yapma etme
demesine rağmen ama ben yeni yollara
yelken açmak istiyorum o güvenlik Konfor
alından çıkmak kendimi keşfetmek
istiyorum Bu sayede Bugün buradayım
onbinlere yüzbinlere ilham olmaya
çalışıyor o Her Ayrılık her terk ediş
Beni daha iyi versiyonuna getirdi ve bir
cümle duydum Keşke bu cümleyi On yaşında
14 yaşında 18 yaşında duysaydım ve
anlamını bilseydin en sık görüştüğünüz
beş kişinin ortalamasını diyordu O Elsa
görüşürüz beş kişi kahvede okeyler birer
dolar onu oynuyor Siz de ona
dönüyorsunuz o beş kişi sigara içiyor
Siz de ona dönüyorsunuz sağlıksız
besleniyorlar hiç spor yapmıyorlar mı
sizde ona dönüyorsunuz bütün gün oturup
diziler maçlar televizyonlar izliyor
Bütün hafta öyle mi geçiyor Siz de ona
dönüyorsunuz hiç kendilerine yatırım
yapmıyorlar bütün gün dedikodumu
yapıyorlar Sürekli Olumsuz negatif
konuşup cesaretiniz mi kırıyorlar Siz de
öyle dene dönüyorsunuz ya da bunun tam
tersi en sık görüşürüz beş kişi sürekli
olumlu pozitif konuşuyor sizi
cesaretlendiriyor mu sürekli kişisel
gelişimde yatırımı yapıyor siz de öyle
bir oluyorsunuz sağlığına dikkat mi bu
formu yapıyor siz de öyle bir Ne
oluyorsunuz yepyeni fikirleri projeleri
tartışıyorlar Hatta milyon dolarlarını
konuşuyorlar Siz de öyle bir
dönüyorsunuz O beş kişinin gelirlerini
toplayın beşe bölün işte sizin gelininiz
bu resimli anlatıyor bilmiyorum ama 15
kişinin tam doğrulamasını anlatıyor
unutmayın en sık görüştüğünüz beş
kişinin ortalaması
İyi o zaman en sık görürsünüz Beş kişiye
bakın eğer size aşağı çekiyorlar sace
saatinizi kuruyorlar sa sizi daha iyi
olmak yerine daha çok yiyorsa onları da
terk etmeyiz
ve en yakınlarımızı terketmek demişken
Belki de bunlardan en zor evlilik o
yıllarda alıştığımız Annenize babanıza
kurulu ev düzeninden ayrılmak zorundayız
evi terk etmek zorundayız ama Her
Ayrılık Bir başlangıcı da sembolüdür
bugün çok özel bir tarih iki Haziran
Bugün benim evliliğimin şu anda bir yüz
görmek Çünkü ben iki Haziran mm bir
yılında evlendim şimdi Evet evimizde
vardı ama birleştik biz olduk ikimizde
Yıllar İçinde birlikte büyüdük birlikte
genişlik birlikte olgun ulaştık daha iyi
versiyonu mıza geldik
gördüğünüz gibi Her Ayrılık her terk
ediş bizi bir üst versiyonu za daha iyi
halimize getirir peki burada ne
yapacağız İlk yapmamız gereken şey
Konfor alanından çıkma cesareti
göstermek işte hayatımızda o karar
kapıları var ya o kadar kapısını aralama
cesareti ve kendimizi terk edebilirsek O
büyüdü gerçek kendimizi bulabileceğiniz
dünyanın da kapılarını aralamış oluyoruz
o zaman ilk o güvendiğimiz kendimizi
Emin hissettiğimiz Konfor alanından
çıkacağız buradan çıkmak kolay değil ama
Sinan Canan'ı da dediği gibi konfor
çürütür bir kez oradan bir adım
attığınızda artık korku alanı bizi
bekliyor güvenemiyorum kendimize
yapamazsak diyoruz bahaneler seviyoruz
Elalem ne der diyoruz ama eğer ona
açarsak işte öğrenme alanı geliyor yeni
bilgiler öğreniyoruz sınırlarımızı
keşfediyoruz kişisel gelişim çapımız
artıyor ve Konfor alanımız giderek
büyüyor Ve sonunda büyüme alanına
geliyoruz artık Hayaller kuruyoruz
hedefler belirliyoruz planlar
artırıyoruz bir amaç peşinde konuşuyoruz
ve hayallerinizi gerçekleştirmeye
başlıyoruz yepyeni hedefler koyuyoruz
işte kendimizin bir üst versiyona çık bu
notu beynin şu sözünü çok severim Bundan
20 yıl sonra
yapmadığınız şeylerden dolayı
yaptıklarınızdan daha fazla pişman
olacaksınız demiralın ve güvenli
limanlardan Çıkın artık her şey ama her
şey o Konfor alanından çıkmaktan geçiyor
Peki nasıl çıkacağız bu kontrol anda
Gelin bugün size son bir soru daha
sorayım bir Istakoz kadar cesaretli
misiniz Istakoz ne ne cesareti olabilir
ki biliyorsunuz takozları Sen sert
kabukları olan deniz canlıları
bu Peki bunların ne cesareti var ilk kez
bunu Psikiyatrist Dr Abraham twerski
sinin bir hikayesi de dinlemiştim
ıstakozlar biliyorsunuz Tıpkı Bizler
gibi ufacık Bebekken büyümeye
çalışıyorlar ama o kendini koruyacak
sağlam kabuğu bir süre sonra onun
düşmanı haline dönüyor Çünkü Büyüyor
büyüyor büyüyor ama sınıra geliyor kabuk
o kadar sert ki İnsan derisi gibi
elastik değil büyüyemiyor Onun içinde
sıkışıyor sıkışıyor sıkışıyor daha fazla
bilmek istiyor ama kabuğun içinde o sert
kabuğun içinde sıkışmış durumda İşte o
zaman Istakoz bir karar vermek zordu o
kabuğunu kırmak zorunda Ama bu kolay
değil kabuk çok sert kendine güvenli bir
yer olması lazım Çünkü diğer deniz
canlıları ona saldırabilir ölebilir önce
güvenli bir yer buluyor sonra o sert
kabuğu kırmak zorunda Her seferinde taşa
vura vura canı acı da o kabağı kırıyor
ve daha büyük bir kabuk inşa ediyor
zamanla o kabuğun içinde de büyüyor ve
yine sınıra geliyor bu sefer işi daha da
zor Çünkü daha büyük daha sert bir
kabuğu var Ve yine aynı işlemi yapıyor
güvenli bir yer buluyor Ve vuruyor
vuruyor vuruyor vuruyor Oka bırakılıyor
ve bunu yaşamı boyunca defalarca kez
yapıyor şimdi sorun sizi Hayatınız
boyunca kaç kez kabuğunu kırma acımasına
ağrımasına zorlanmasına rağmen kaç kez
kabuğunu kırma cesareti gösterdiniz bir
Istakoz kadar cesur olabildiğiniz
insanlar büyük hedefler koyup
ulaşamadıkları için değil küçük hedefler
koyup ulaştıkları için potansiyellerini
yaşayanlar
istakozlar kadar cesur musunuz demiştim
farkında mısınız ıstakozlar belirli
zamanlarda kabuklarını kırıp ken ve
yeniden onarmak yaratılışları gereği
tekrar tekrar kendilerinden yeniden
doğmak zorunda var peki ya siz bize
verilen alarmın farkında mısınız stres
sıkıntı üzüntü ve daha nicesi hepsi
hayatı bir gerçeği ama bilmeliyiz ki bu
haller aslında bir alarmını uyanmamız
için çalan sesleri Kimimiz büyüdükçe
mevcut işlerimizin kendimize dar
geldiğini fark edeceğiz kimimizin
çevremizin bizi aşağı çektiğini görecek
ve değiştirmek isteyeceğiz Kimimiz de
yapmamız değiştirmemiz dönüştürmemiz
gereken türlü şeyleri kendimize
keşfedeceğiz
daralma sıkılma sıkışma
hissettiğimizde hatırlamamız lazım gelen
tek bir şey var Bunlar kendimize
sığamadı ımızın birer göstergesi bitmesi
gereken bir konunun büyümenin gelişmenin
daha iyi bir hayatın daha iyi bir ben
olmanın vakti gelmiş demektir
ne yapılması gereken ne midir Elbette ki
kabuğunu kırmak ve kendimizi baştan
aşağı yeniden onarmak yeniden
canlandırmak tır iyi bir üstünde dediği
gibi yumurta dıştan kırılırsa yaşam son
bulur Ama içerden kalırsa yaşam başlar
Gelin bugün kapanışı da Ahmet Hamdi
Tanpınar dan yapan
ama hiç kendini denemeyecek misin ne
olduğunu kim olduğunu keşfetmeden
göreceksin diyor
Selam bugün Eğer bu sunumu izliyorsanız
bu konuşmayı izliyorsanız artık kabuğun
uzun size yetmediğini kabuğu kırmanın
vaktinin geldiğini kendinizi daha yeni
bir versiyonu için herkes etmeniz
gerektiğini anladığımız oluyor ve Gelin
bugün yeni denizlere yeni okyanuslara
yelken açalım yeni Bize ulaşmak için
kabukları mızı kıralım Konfor alanı terk
edelim ve kendi potansiyelimizi
keşfetmek için kendimizi terkedelim hadi
Hadi yola çıkalım Hadi cesaretle ava at
[Alkış]